citizens of the reject Nation we are
going to watch Chucky season dose
episode Uno today John how are you I am
Giddy and excited and I can't wait how
are you I am excited I also cannot wait
and giddy simultaneously Trifecta ladies
and gentlemen uh if you watch any of our
TV reactions you'll know that we always
say this that full-length Reaction watch
along as we sync up with your own copy
available for super sexy Rejects at our
patreon page but this time around uh the
first episode it's gonna be available
for everyone so if you want to sync up
with us watch along with us there's a
link in the description box where you
can go ahead and do that that would be
awesome but the rest would be patreon
exclusives in the meantime go ahead
leave a like that'd be very much
appreciated another thing I really gotta
mention probably heard a lot of people
talking about this lately I've seen some
videos go trending and it's been
happening almost quite a bit there's a
lot of uh age restrictions and a lot of
YouTube you know punishing videos for
things being like PG-13 so this is
Chucky you know so we might have to once
in a while mute some words or hide a
little bit of certain sequences because
of the nature of the show please
understand that when something does get
age restricted or hit with limited ads
that also means that YouTube just
doesn't promote the video at all so it
doesn't even like get any views and it's
a crappy situation being when you spend
several hours putting one of these
videos together
some of that YouTube stuff let's get to
it
Are We There Yet when do we get to start
stabbing people wait you got a knife
yeah I got a knife they passed them out
at orientation what the [ __ ]
I didn't say anything
worry
they say all guys are more zero
I don't have stick arms hey
do I know you bet your ass you do
don't make me come back there
she is
not hot
they don't know what she did you just
keep your mouth shut Buster
man what if they kill off Andy in the
first scene
[Music]
oh damn
[Music]
Andy oh [ __ ]
that doesn't last long
[Music]
Sinister
nightmare at 15 feet
[Music]
this is for Kyle
oh my God I better get a kill off Annie
in this opening scene
[Music]
[Applause]
we didn't see it happen we only heard it
happen got a fell Acosta this time ah
yeah
he seems okay
I wish I could say the same about pamel
Larry
Stefan staying behind I want to kiss you
so bad right now but go for it they're
watching
you guys can at least hug yeah seriously
I love you more Devin oh
not possible
uh considering Jake's obsession with
your podcast I would say that Jake Paul
probably does love you more yeah
you don't have any of Jake's art I mean
it's a good shot
Jake
oh wait stop stop
oh that's really touching
they just drive off
holy secret identity
that's my secret Robin
[ __ ]
it's trust as bad
you scared me it's called color of
phobia the fear of clowns is caused by
childhood trauma
what are you doing out here all alone
like where are your parents your friends
they're dead
okay
hahaha
well edited yeah
ooh respect always goes to a good jump
scare
it's time to go fight some crime
citizens of Gotham will pay Us in
chocolate
sorry give me a second
hello is Tamara
who you'd recognize that Voice come on
man come on I think you have the wrong
number oh
sorry
oh yeah it happens no worries oh my God
we're doing a screen reference would it
be the first time
where the hell are you
I'm so sorry Devin I'm not gonna be able
to make it you're gonna do this now
you're supposed to be on the bus Jake
I'm cooking for you here man oh
you're still not cool with us scream
they're not your real parents I didn't
think they'd actually be homophobic yeah
where's your boyfriend tonight Jake
screw you Ellis hey you know what Ellis
you know it's bad enough that you're a
homophobic douchebag prick you know the
really sad thing is it's totally
unoriginal this isn't Ellis and I'm not
homophobic
Jake I just got a weird call from this
douchebag wait he called you too
doesn't he sound kind of
familiar
oh Devin you know you don't think you
can take I don't think anything could
have survived that crash
not even Andy I never found his body
yes yeah confirmed
[Laughter]
whatever
that's him oh
[Music]
what the hell oh no
that Lexi's home that's not very scary
what are you supposed to be here
ghost of Halloween past say hello to my
friends hi
okay no wonder she doesn't recognize
yes I have to record a break in at 3083
Fairburn
damn that is pretty scary
I'm gonna get that nope
[Music]
you know what you you should die yeah I
saw you ignore my phone call ghost Mead
Lexi you have done this before right
have you
first time should be special
oh okay okay first I just need a bump
me too Lexi no what have you become
traumatized
please Jesus Christ
you kids okay
how are you doing here did my mother
send you we got a report of a break-in
I'm gonna have a look around yeah I
should go sit down have sex
was there anyone else in the house
tonight
the ghost of Halloween passed he has to
use the bathroom
he said it was an emergency oh
yeah
how tall was this ghost
well he was about this tall
this is just a misunderstanding would
you mind staying with us until my mother
gets home
sure
is that cocaine
it does nothing
even sleep without waking up screaming
every night from the nightmares
and she made me get rid of all of her
dolls yes it's called pediophobia that's
the clinical term for fear of dolls I'm
going to learn a lot of terms this
episode
you know I collect dolls recreationally
is she gonna bring a good guy doll in
here
this is Belle
Caroline I think Belle could help you
would you like to hold her you can do it
support group of Chucky
she needs someone to take care of her
let's take her home
you know there's someone watching them
at the grave uh at the end of last
season what if it was that therapist
I I wouldn't put it past it
that doll is destined to wake up I think
I apply a unique position of empathy I
know exactly what they're going through
because
I'm going through it too
the guilt
the survivors guilt
[Laughter]
Caroline how about you I'm fine
hey what ever happened to Chucky
yo Caroline does Bell tell you to do
things too
what are you talking about
we have it on tape get out
[Music]
and that's the article that's the entire
headline yo
friends
[Laughter]
never trust any doll never trust any
doll okay
okay good and you can't tell anyone or
they're gonna send you away okay
not liking this approach Lexi yeah
well so much could go wrong maybe a
smaller knife too a kid's knife if
Chucky really was at her house last
night then why did he kill her when you
had the chance
is messing with us
maybe he's trying to get one of us to
kill again
is that doll from a previous movie
it's got a new drug every scene
Devin what did you find out about
Caroline's doll well she looks a little
like the Bride of Chucky
remember that movie yeah with Jennifer
Tilly
who we know really is the Bride of
Chucky
Tiffany Valentine
back to all that super meta territory
I'm thinking like yeah did the Tiffany
doll get some kind of different makeover
that's right Seed of Chucky they made
the Bride of Chucky movie yeah yes yeah
did you test it
I bashed the [ __ ] out of it
all right Lexi
[ __ ] it's my mom um get in the closet
you can't put them back in the closet at
least they're in there together
[Music]
let's see it
[Music]
nice they teased us about her since the
first season we were pretty famous for a
while after the murders and there are
some sick [ __ ] out there with way
too much time on their hands yeah some
sick [ __ ] was able to get all our
numbers and it also happens to be just
two feet tall
short people can be [ __ ]
woke
it just you seem weird you're weird
okay where are you going
to the bathroom is that okay with you
[Music]
never got confirmation that Chucky left
no
he's got to be hiding out watching the
chaos
or heck maybe even a couple
[Music]
Chucky the Euphoria season
yeah let's get a hypnotic Montage going
[Music]
what
what
you're not playing it right
still alive aren't I
for long
what
[Music]
damn this is really happening this is
crazy
holy awesome situation Batman okay
that's already getting old Gary it's
gonna be okay he's gonna blow us on The
Smithereens no no I won't let that
happen I promise this isn't a game okay
I don't think Gary's worried about that
no Gary is on board
well now you're all Gonna Get Busy Dying
it just as soon as Lexi gets down here
oh thank God she's doing drugs
drugs save lives
why are you doing this there were 72 of
me on that truck I was gonna take over
the world and I would have gotten away
with it too if it weren't for you
meddling kids uh jinkies
I'm gonna kill every last one of these
oh my God if the doll's alive Belle yeah
enough to make this worth the sacrifice
I die knowing I took all of you with me
you die knowing best secret texter
no
[Music]
God I love my job
Redemption
[Music]
what the hell Gary
what are you about to do Gary
[Music]
that got me man
you and your friends have denied Gary
his life if I may their children too
and they'll be placed
in a facility with other violent
juvenile offenders like them oh no
military school
these kids are responsible for Gary's
death
yet I'm sure we all agree
it was a tragic
it was a Kamikaze mission
he blew himself up
he's never done anything like that
before
which means that more than one Chucky
made it out of that truck crash a lot
thousand percent how many
who knows no matter what
he's gonna come for us again
internet Voodoo
these guys are going to be together
yeah all the time hey do you guys
remember Trevor Kane he made my life a
living hell
taught me everything I know and he went
here
my mother sent him here
wait guys why is this place look so
familiar
to be the product in home for Wayward
boys
yeah I had janitor's body is still
probably out here rotting
yeah that therapist is totally connected
man I bet she was the one watching them
at the grave
yeah now I'm thinking back like
you know why you're here
God Hates Us he wants you to see
just find your way back
if you're not careful you might even
have a little fun along the way Jesus is
a radical dude
[Music]
you can Crush that communion bread and
snort it yeah
and these two are going to be fine
Catholic Church oh yeah they're
supportive love the queer community
getting shipped
no
[Music]
Christ
[Music]
I guess we should wait to see if there's
a post credit scene I like that the
puppeteers got co-starring credits
God does it go that fast on actual
sci-fi Network
subscribe damn it I'll be back I always
come back and so should you
should you nice all right let's talk
about it yep you're right yeah okay my
rusty memory yeah Tiffany it's the the
rule you say it you're the one you
remember properly Tiffany brings him the
bridal doll is like a gift yeah before
you know he does the whole like I'm
gonna electrocute you in the bathtub and
we're gonna transfer your soul and then
you know make over montage and all that
good stuff I was so wrapped up I
couldn't remember that whole passage
in the moment no I did a did a big bench
recently and I was like that doll looks
familiar but it's not coming to me right
now well yeah and it's like you know the
the middle ones like I like bride and
Seed but they are probably the ones I've
seen the least times maybe maybe while
three I haven't watched three that many
times but that's part of what makes this
series so beautiful is because like the
first I mean the third one's not good
but the first two are good so like those
charms yeah yeah yeah it's easily at the
bottom like like I will take can't be
jokey Chucky and other things away
before I'll take a military school
Chucky because yeah the first the first
sale even get the third one Rick I guess
a sense of seriousness and then bride of
Chucky's when it's easy again it's like
that's what I got into the 90s so yeah
it's really meta and crazy I mean that's
when there's no cedar truck is really
are you going to the early 2000s even
maybe by then maybe yeah that was in the
second one in like 1990 or something
like that I don't know release date yeah
so there's Seed of Chucky and then
there's a curse came around was that's
when I started gain like back to being
serious yeah that's actually being scary
and the cult was like art art house yeah
and what I love about this show is that
it's a great embodiment of all that I
think it does I think it's like the
culmination of all the different things
Don Mancini had set out to do over the
course of this franchise but this one
has the most heart out of them all like
there's such a there's such a heart
about it like I really care about these
kids yeah man absolutely you care about
them as characters and I think you know
the best of of the movies have often
done that too you know and that's why
it's such a joy when certain characters
come to I mean we didn't get Nika this
episode uh but you know that's why it is
a joke
I know I know this is like the most
horrific send-off for a character and
and like you know I'm glad for the
anticipation like I do like the way
because the Chucky franchise 2 has gone
through its various
um you know
not ups and downs but you know like at
times they want to show Chucky less and
really build them up and other times we
want to throw a bunch of Chucky right at
you and this one you know starts with
with a lot of Chuck and then the rest of
it yeah this is like a steady build up
to that and yeah we're getting a steady
build back to whatever Anika and Tiffany
are off doing
yeah I mean that's a big part why I
really respect this franchise is because
of the variety it offers and its
commitment to it and doesn't ignore what
it did before yeah it responds to it
yeah and I think that's a great way to
proceed with your as you develop it it's
like you never feel like there's softer
rebooting it you know even even when
they sort of do but yeah like there's
always some kind of connective tissue
and they're always really good at using
whatever setting they chew like maybe
aside from the military camp but you
know like but even the carnival in that
movie like yeah the the first season has
such a great sort of yes small town
paranoia sordid Affairs kind of thing
happening and you know these you know
relatable uh just you know high school
and love stories and things like that
and now here I'm really excited to see
where this goes in terms of yeah we have
to address the sort of Happily Never
After of it all but then segwaying into
this ostensibly like this Catholic
boarding school of some kind I think is
a really cool and fun idea and I can't
wait to see how that setting and all the
themes that come with that setting are
going to influence the story and also
you know bring out the devious sides and
the characters but also bring out sides
of Chucky we haven't seen yet well I I
kind of feel a bit of a stranger things
influence with this oh yeah especially
with season the way they're setting up
season two you know I know they're very
different shows and about the only
common things you can draw are the
teenagers and you know horror events and
they're the only ones who know the truth
yeah you know so there's actually some
very big similarities you can draw
amongst it all Supernatural
um and you know like when you look at
the movies that was they they never
other than Child's Play Three
bash session today it didn't really deal
with uh you know the teenager side of it
it's like Annie was always a little
there was a little kid and then he was
in military school which isn't your
normal teenage experience absolutely and
then the way I like in this and the way
I felt about stranger things season two
was that
um it was such a response to the first
season you're watching them deal with
the post-traumatic stress disorder of
the events that occurred in the first
season and how that's carrying over here
and that's really Lexi who gets to uh
really take that on and oh my God what
is Lexi's sister's name
just keep going and I'll do the Google
this well what I what I really respect
about it is the fact that they're
dealing with it and allowing them to be
in different directions and you're
seeing sort of a flip-flop of situations
because yeah as Disturbed Caroline as um
Jake is by this situation and and Devin
as well they they have their traumas
from it they've also seemed to Garner
especially for Jake who was a lot more
timid in the last season and it was a
lot more you know introverted and this
time around even though he's dealing
with the traumas of what's occurred
there is more of a strength that he puts
out there and like proceeds with kind of
an angry confidence versus Lexi who in
in the last season you know obviously
there was like a Bravado that she had up
and she was like the the Mean Girl until
she did such a good job by the way
making her likable after I wanted her to
die and then now we pick up with her and
she's the one who's the like falling
apart the most yeah out of the three of
them which is not what I would expect
going into this like literally the only
thing I like I've heard the the talk
about like Glenn and Glenda coming in
this show and I've heard and I only saw
the image of the bald Chucky those are
the only two things I've really heard
about so I don't I didn't know exactly
what we'd be getting into
this Catholic School element is the
thing you said yeah between I saw some
straight quote from Don Mancini saying
like I I have a thing for yeah that sort
of unofficial sub-genre of Catholic
horror and I wanted to do something with
that or anybody who grew up Catholic
might get something out of this you know
which I was like I was very intrigued I
was like what does that even mean but
also like that I grew up Catholic let's
do that we both do yeah yeah so our boys
up in here you're right get that right
trip and Christ in Christ of course you
get to leave class for an hour pray
devoted and uh you were man you would go
to church after school yeah and one
people laughed at me I know and then I
tried to follow your example for a
minute
like it's on the same property
she had a point
that's a bad example going to church
he's going in there tempting all those
Wayward kidnappers
well I mean I didn't know this till
while we were shooting the reactions for
Chucky season one The domancini he is
homosexual right yeah
so I I imagine that like that's what I
mean I don't I just 100 do not identify
as Catholic anymore yeah and uh the
homosexual oppression part is I can
imagine they they would deal well that's
one thing that I credit the show for for
dealing with and I feel like they would
have to address that oh within the
Catholic Church 150 like I have a
feeling and I think don don Mancini is I
think if you have a thing for that you
know for any religious skewing horror
you must have grown up with some kind of
religiosity in your life but yeah like I
Chucky always sort of exists to bring
out and expose you know all the darkness
in people so like yeah having him run
around here I I have absolutely no doubt
that we'll get into yeah like the the
queer oppressions of the Catholic church
but also all the other sort of dirty and
uh you know just sort of low motivations
that lie there with within the humans
who are trying to uphold this thing and
who are trying to you know spread the
ideology Chucky hasn't done like the
full-on religious horror have they
that's like the whole thing with the
voodoo it's always been a demonology
type of horror yeah but they haven't
done the I'm trying to think now it's
like has Chucky killed me freaking
Horror Story to Asylum but in the
Catholic Church yeah yeah which I think
is good and I was sort of thinking as
they were walking in the door I was like
I kind of feel like a little bit
American Horror Story right now that's
why I I've even even the ones that are
tough to sit through I respect the
franchise so much because of its
willingness to do something so different
like the way this picked up
it was like oh we're doing we're picking
up exactly where like we're we're like
moments from where we left off of it's
like the continuation of a scene of
where we're leaving off on and then as
we're going through it it's like yeah
okay this feeling like season two of
Chuck of the Chucky show and then by the
point of where we ended it it was like
oh this might actually be doing
something very different which is what I
kind of want yeah because of how the
franchise works well and I think that's
part of what has made the franchise
itself Timeless is like I've only grown
appreciation for it over time because
the first like the first movie is such a
succinctly good idea like even remove
the voodoo and the murder it's just like
you know your doll and your kid and like
there's something very simple and Primal
that works about that and then you know
yeah you have the other movies shifting
in genre borrowing things from different
horror movies and it's like you've
watched other slasher franchises do
versions of that but I don't think with
as much sort of adeptness as the Chucky
movie have and yeah their installments
people like better than others and not
everybody loves the completely jokey
2000s era but yeah it all comes back
together when you see the way in which
they use all those different elements
and the way that the franchise doesn't
ever seem Keen to you know disavow any
one installment or another and again
like there's so many great things to to
play off of like Chucky is a great
character because whereas so many
slashers are you know like Freddy preys
on people's fears and things about them
but I feel like Chucky really like gets
his hooks in people and really twists
them inside out so you have the kills
and the slasher stuff but you also just
have like a unique
character affect that comes with him and
you can explore things like traumas in a
way that a lot of other slasher movies
decide not to because they'll just like
bring back returning characters kill
them in the first minute to do a cold
open yeah whereas here it's like yeah
you really feel the life in the
aftermath of so many things and I'm
trying to do something different every
time yeah so I respect it I respect it
quite a bit and to be fair too like I I
I'm pleased that the show is as big as
it is and that it has such like a strong
queer element because I feel like it
might be easy for people to go oh it's
just the times but like yeah like it's
always kind of been there there have
always been aspects or interesting
one-off characters or you know not that
not the Chucky movies are like the be
all end-all of progress but like they
Ford that you know conversation have
often been more Progressive than you
would think
yeah and then sometimes you still get
some wacky and wackadoodle characters
like uh
like Jake's younger brother oh what the
hell was going on there what's up Gary
yeah
what happened to you you were the
sweetest and now you're completely like
detached and psychotic he's like bomb
he's gonna he's good he's gonna be don't
worry Gary I'm not gonna happen he's
like yay I was like are you is is it the
is the beat that he's just so into
playing this like childlike Fantasy game
or does he have any grasp of what's
going on I don't I think I I think he
doesn't realize that that's a real bum
yeah and that the doll is like really
alive or something but yeah in the
moment it is like whoa wait a minute
what and I think Lexi's mom's gonna die
I think she is I like the beat they go
with her but I feel like she will die
Maybe by Seasons oh yeah she's such a
sociopath she's like trying to use her
trauma that doesn't seem like real
trauma but then they give like a couple
of tender moments that feel genuine that
bedroom scene where yeah she comes in
and there's the whole lullaby lie yeah
like that was a nice soft scene and then
there's the stuff where she's running
for mayor or at least she gets defensive
for the little girl what's her name
Caroline Caroline it's defensively
Caroline and gets defensive for her uh
and then also
um but it's but I I do like when she's
trying to use survivor's guilt that's a
way to win some votes in a pitiful way
in the worst sort of yeah a rich white
feminist way of doing so yeah funny
stuff man
and I do think that therapist I mean the
fact that she had that doll
yeah now and the way that it is like
gifted and and yeah leads right to
Charles Lee Ray's home so now I've
already grew up yeah the Wayward boys
Academy I'm like uh and at the same time
I mean it would make more sense that
she's involved with Chucky but part of
me wonders like
I don't know you know it's it is the
Tiffany Bridal thing like is the you
know like Tiffany is clearly not in
Chucky's corner at the moment but also
like would there be some kind of
you know connect there well there's one
thing this franchise knows how to do is
surprise us with some important piece of
lineage or lore yeah connectivity
usually something to do with that's how
Charles Lee Ray was cut then
there's another addition to how he was
cut Spider-Man three he made a lot of
stops with Eddie Caputo along the way
before ultimately running into that Toy
Story
yeah you were on their 12th stop he had
to murder her because Mom and you had to
do this thing and that thing he probably
went to church on the way yeah there's
always some addition to what got Charlie
Rich hey man if that leads to more uh uh
uh Fiona duraf in Brad duraf makeup I'm
all for it well we learned in the in the
last season that uh Tiffany is the one
who ratted him out yeah
um to the cops so
yeah there's got to be another element
of that because I feel like we explore
like what else is there to explore about
Charles Lee Ray's backstory because I
feel like you're going to go here and
it's a big part of what you're going to
explore
is there something more just another
Nifty little detail because we kind of
went pretty heavy last season yeah I
mean I'm sure they can surprise us I
wonder if maybe they might give us some
of like the humanity in surprising ways
because like we've seen so much of his
you know formative you know psychopath
moments as of last season and so maybe
being here you'll see
the instead of seeing the part that was
always there that was you know the The X
Factor that makes you know a a Michael
Myers or a Charles Lee Ray or whatever
it is maybe we'll see the ways in which
this environment helped shape him or
something because the core of season one
from my emotional experience with it was
that it was significantly spotlighting
bullying primarily it was it was like
the main thing yeah of course like
domestic violence and all those kinds of
shades of abuse but bullying was like
the a very prevalent topic yeah uh in
that season and I I don't know what this
one will be dealing with some I feel
like some form of Oppression yeah which
is as a shade a major shade of of the
last season
to thrust you into the Catholic church
and then some of these things with like
talking to Caroline our murder name
kudos to you Greg when she's like Look
No One's Gonna believe you so you just
gotta you gotta go with the story yeah
and beyond that though it's like you
can't tell anyone the truth because no
one will accept you okay you know like
that's another way to sort of interpret
it yeah you'll be sent away no and
that's a great theme is is we live in a
time now where more than ever it's easy
to feel like you have to keep your head
down and play the game but also tell you
like
the truth should always be out there
yeah this is a fun episode but it wasn't
as fun as I ex like anticipated it would
be not saying that's bad I was like oh
there's some genuine tense stuff here
even the Chucky scene yeah the the one
we you finally wait for him to he
finally shows up you know and uh
when he does it's really like this is
suspenseful yeah this isn't funny you
know no and it's a nice clever like yeah
the whole thing about like I'm just
trying to get everybody in the room
together it's like it's so simple and
yet even still it's another clever sort
of diabolical scheme
you know that takes a little a little
Ingenuity like it's convoluted in just
the right way yeah yeah
and it's like yeah it's high up to like
you know tie up my remaining Loose Ends
move on
we didn't see the person at the
graveyard right that was the whole thing
there was a hand on the tree yeah
leather gloves that's what my mind's
telling me now they're wearing gloves or
with a hand thing you got to look out
here yeah you can't make out who it was
but yeah like not a therapist she's
suspect number one to me yeah well and
and is Andy really dead that's the other
question no I didn't see it you can't
kill off Andy but you know what I my
prediction is that he will if this
season
my prediction for one of the higher
concept elements is I wonder if he will
come back with some kind of like
horrific disfigurement a la the various
disfigurements Chucky undergoes because
you know the more Andy is involved with
this the more wrapped up and and you
know crazed he's going to become right
especially after this
here we are guys Chucky two by one thank
you so much for being here uh leave a
like subscribe and uh what'd you think
about this Premiere episode leave your
thoughts down below let's end this with
a patreon
flev door and if anyone's gonna be your
friend to the end it is fleb flev is
such a positive chipper upbeat guy and I
don't trust it Flav I don't trust it at
all in fact I feel like you would
probably be the kind of guy to transfer
your soul into a body get to know me get
to feel like we are really the best of
friends and then boom I'm doing your
dirty work for you flev what's up with
that man you know what it's okay though
because hey we all need a friend like
you we all need to indulge in the
darkness once in a while and if anybody
is chalked to the brim with nihilism
it's you flev so uh hey stay on caring
cold and detached and we'll catch you
next month love you buddy
[Music]